this is a moment where we're not begging
for change were demanding change there's
a voice being heard through them through
the world I mean what do you think of
George Floyd what does he represent at
this point George Floyd represents
sacrifice represents urgency and
represents immediate immediate change
there is this whole dynamics of talking
about being a good Ally ship and being
an effective I like [ __ ] what do you
want to see when it comes to being an
ally a movement conversation I'd love to
see what processes and protocols in
place what's your hiring process yeah
who's in your communications department
your department it's right in your media
messaging you know your panels and your
committees and all that that's that's
what I'd like to see I'd like to support
the diversity and inclusion I'd like to
see them training on racism anti black
racism mm-hmm movement movement gotta
make movement happen and you may
movement happen when you were doing
Caroline or a change in her musical
theatre debut earlier this year in
Toronto Julie took on the title role of
Caroline to tell a story about ordinary
people facing extraordinary change
following the Kennedy assassination and
civil rights movement the timing
everything education is the key and you
you blew me away just the fact that you
were part of a project like that what
does it mean to be able to do something
like that right before all this happens
this is where you for me I come to
realize that everything is exactly how
and where it should be
even the damnation the trial the
tribulation is how you use it to channel
who you want to become make your next
move your best move